in der rheinland pfälzischen
landeshauptstadt mainz bekommt so
lichtner vor einigen tagen post
er traut seinen augen nicht eine
mieterhöhung um vier prozent und das
ausgerechnet jetzt da wegen der korona
krise viele mieter darum bangen wie sie
über die runden kommen sollen
ich muss ehrlich gesagt erst mal lachen
ich kann es nicht fassen sozusagen der
vermieter ist nicht etwa eine dieser
gefürchteten anonymen immobilienfonds
nein es ist die kommunale
wohnungsbaugesellschaft der stadt die
wohnbau mainz 4300 solcher
mieterhöhungen hat die mainzer wohnbau
in der vergangenen woche verschickt in
dem schreiben droht der städtische
vermieter sogar an die forderungen vor
gericht durchzusetzen schriftlich heißt
es anderenfalls müssten wir klage
erheben viele der betroffenen mieter
halten das für eine frechheit
die wortwahl der wurm war die ganze zeit
hatten effekt dass man natürlich wenn
man sowas liest wie eine klage auf
zustimmung
man hat natürlich angst wir haben
whatsapp gruppe unter nachbarn und die
zeige ich ihnen jetzt nicht was da drin
steht aber da wurde natürlich
entsprechen darüber ausgetauscht
nach dem öffentlichen aufschrei ist die
wohnbau mainz mittlerweile
zurückgerudert vor der kamera wird sich
niemand äußern
man verweist auf eine pressemitteilung
dort heißt es wir werden die
mieterhöhungen nicht umsetzen auch
weitere mieterhöhungen wird es vorerst
nicht geben
doch die mieter der wohnbau trauen dem
frieden nicht
da die bombe hat sich noch nicht
entschuldigt die wohnbau hat aber jetzt
darauf hingewiesen dass sie die
mieterhöhung zurücknehmen wollen
zurücknehmen wollen in diesem kontext
heißt natürlich nur dass aufgeschoben
wird das ist einfach unmöglich das jetzt
zu machen die wohnungsbaugesellschaft
hat mit ihrer versuchten mieterhöhung
bei ihren mietern viel vertrauen
zerstört